[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> I would like for
you to picture the first time you
kissed someone you really liked.
>> [LAUGH]
>> How did you feel?
Did you have this funny
feeling in your stomach?
Where you're flying,
few inches above the ground maybe.
This is an example of something
that I call a goosebump moment.
I love goosebump moments.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They make me feel present, they make me
feel connected, and
they make me feel alive.
And there are three things that
never fail to give goosebumps.
Apart from kissing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Climbing mountains.
This is me climbing Mont Blanc
in Europe last summer.
Listening to my favorite music.
And yes, tomorrow with my friends,
we are going to Los Angeles to see Red Hot
Chili Peppers live in their home city.
I'm so excited for this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And finally,
basically, everything
about space exploration.
And today, I would like to share with you
my favorite moments in
the history of space exploration.
Let's begin with our
journey with our one and
only natural satellite
you all know as the moon.
You know the story.
Everything started in the late 1950s.
Two super countries decided
to join the space race and
send people to the most expensive
picnic in the history of humankind.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes, picnic.
Even though it cost $200 billion by
today's value of money, $200 billion.
Landing on the moon had no
major scientific value.
This is literally what I was told when
I was visiting Kennedy Space Center,
last summer.
But yet it gives me goose bumps even
now when I'm thinking about it.
Ever since life began on our planet 3.8
billion years ago, this is the first
time we managed to leave our planet and
land on another astronomical body.
The same astronomical body, that our
ancestors had been seeing for thousand and
thousand of years on their clear
night sky but could never reach.
Can you imagine that NASA
was founded in 1958 and
managed to put humans on
the moon in only 11 years.
I mean, YouTube is 12 years old.
And it's not even profitable probably.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Let me tell you about my
favorite goosebumps moment from that time.
You've probably all seen the sun rise or
the moon rise, right?
There is a picture from that time,
which is my favorite and
it's called the Earth rise.
I like this picture so
much that I even printed it, framed, and
it's sitting in my apartment
back in Poland where I'm from.
This picture was taken by an astronaut,
William Anders on Christmas Eve 1968.
And the reason why I put this picture in
my apartment is to remind me to always
keep everything in a proper perspective.
You see,
ever since famous astronomer Nicholas or
Nicholas Copernicious as you
may know him in English.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We knew that we are,
we knew that we are not
the center of the universe.
But not, for the first time,
we could actually see it.
Let me put it this way.
When you were a child,
your whole universe,
your whole world, was just your house and
maybe a backyard.
And then, when you were growing up,
your world was expanding to your school,
to your neighborhood,
to the whole city, to other cities,
to the whole country, to other countries.
And for some of us, even continents.
With every new prospective, of every
new place you get a new prospective.
And that's exactly why
the Earth rise is so important.
This is the first time we as humanity
gained this new prospective.
Collectively, for
that reason the Earth rise was dubbed one
of the most important pictures
in the history of human kind.
It's a symbol for
cause to global unity and peace and
it also started modern
environmental movement So
landing on the moon and getting this new
perspective is our first goosebump moment.
In the next 40 years,
we did to space exploration the same
thing Michael Jordan did to basketball.
We made going to space look easy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we kept going,
we preformed the study with 131
succesful launchers of space travel.
We built a big bed of camrock
called Hubble Space Telescope
that we sent into space to take
deep pictures of deep space.
We also created a flying craft called the
International Space Station where we can
conduct experiments in microgravity.
Beginning of 1970s, we started
sending out a number of unmanned
spacecrafts in order to explore
beyond our low Earth orbit.
There was probably eight
of them that are important.
But my favorite, by far, is Voyager 1.
Voyager 1 was launched in 1977.
So 40 years ago.
And currently, it's 20 billion
kilometers from planet Earth.
It's the first object to leave our solar
system in the history of human kind.
And also, since the beginning of my
speech, it already traveled 3,000 miles,
which makes it also the fastest
object we ever created.
The original mission of the Voyager
was to take pictures of Jupiter and
Saturn, and this brings me to my
second favorite goosebumps moment.
After passing Jupiter,
NASA decided to turn Voyager around and
take the last picture of our
solar system from a distance.
Here is a part of this picture.
In the middle you can see a tiny dot,
over there, let me help you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This tiny dot is our planet and
this picture is called the pale blue dot.
It's not beautiful and it, again,
it has no major scientific value but let
me quote fragments with famous astronomer
Carl Sagan said about this picture.
That's home.
On it everyone you ever heard of,
every young couple in love,
every hopeful child, every mother and
father, every saint and
sinner in the history of
our species lives there.
On a moat of dust suspended in a sun beam.
Our imagined self importance.
The delusion that we have
some privileged position in
the universe are challenged
by this point of pale light.
It underscores our responsibility to
deal more kindly with one another.
And to preserve and
cherish this pale blue dot.
The only home we've ever known.
Whereas the Earth rise
was about perspective,
the pale blue dot reminds me
how vast the universe is.
And you can get intimidated by
looking at this pale blue dot.
But also, you can turn around and
get excited of how much
more is there to explore.
And this brings me to current days, and
boy, it's hard not to get goosebumps.
There's so
many things happening all the time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just recently,
Elon Musk announced that he's about
to send two private citizens for
a roundtrip around the moon
as soon as end of 2018.
His company SpaceX promises to land
humans on Mars just nine years from now
nine years.
That's a promise is the same.
But I'm not only talking about the big
players I'm talking a little startups like
planets small efficiency small
like this efficient satellites
that are capable of taking high-definition
pictures of our planet's surface.
Or the other startup's
called Made In Space.
They produced the first zero-gravity
3D printer that operates currently
onboard the ISS,
the International Space Station.
With all those things happening,
do you know what gives me goosebumps
when I think about the future?
I have this little dream,
you know that I like mountains, right?
There is a mountain on Mars,
it's called Olympus Mons.
It's 2.5 times taller than
the tallest mountain, Mt Everest.
And in fact,
the tallest mountain in our solar system.
Can you imagine climbing this baby and
listening to Other Side by
Red Hot Chili Peppers on top of it?
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is crazy.
But yet
it's totally possible in my lifespan.
I hope you get at least a little bit
excited about space exploration.
Maybe some of you even got
some goosebump moments.
Let me finish my speech
with one last remark.
Every speech has some tangible
idea that can change your life,
change your organizations,
or change the world.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You may wonder,
what is the tangle idea in my speech?
Well, you're right.
There is none.
My message to you is simply stop
over thinking for a second.
Stop looking for logic all of the time.
Tonight, get out, put your favorite
music on and look up at the stars.
Get yourself a goosebump moment.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]